MEMO: It's magical
just to be here.
I'm thinking about how
many thousands of stones
are overhead, man.
So let's not think
a lot about that.
KENNY BROAD: My
name is Kenny Broad.
I'm the mission specialist.
NARRATOR: Kenny Broad
is a National Geographic
explorer and chief
exploration officer
of the Virtual Wonders Team.
MAN: I would describe Kenny
Broad as a mad scientist.
NARRATOR: As an expert
caver, he and Memo
may be able to add crucial
insight on how to access
the chamber below the pyramid.
MEMO: There's very
few people that have
the privilege to go in here.
KENNY BROAD: I
don't want to wait.
MEMO: All right, let's go.
KENNY BROAD: Being involved
in a new discovery,
it gives you this feeling
that you're doing something
larger than just yourself.
NARRATOR: While there are
no portals to the underworld
on the ground floor, they hike
up to a sacred chamber, which
holds some intriguing clues.
MEMO: And this is
the amazing room.
So beware.
KENNY BROAD: Wow.
Oh, my gosh, that's incredible.
MEMO: Yeah, this is where
the king used to sit.
NARRATOR: This is
the jaguar throne.
KENNY BROAD: So the
king used to sit here.
I mean, it really sticks out
because it still has, I assume,
the original paint?
MEMO: Yes.
NARRATOR: From
this royal throne,
kings watched countless
humans sacrificed to the rain
god Chaac at this nearby altar.
Could their remains lie
in the veiled crypt below?
KENNY BROAD: Those are
the original insets?
Is that jade?
MEMO: This is jade.
NARRATOR: To the Maya, jade
was a royal resource, used
to communicate with the gods.
KENNY BROAD: But there's
no local jade, so--
MEMO: Exactly.
Yeah, they bring it all
the way from Guatemala.
It was one very important item.
Only Royalty had access to it.
This context is not
only a royal context,
where the king used to rest,
sit, it's also a funerary one.
There is a relationship
with death here and life.
KENNY BROAD: Resurrection?
MEMO: Resurrection.
KENNY BROAD: The cycle.
[inaudible] is the cycle.
NARRATOR: The
ornate jaguar throne
sits in front of something
even more grim and ominous.
MEMO: This is an amazing
wall for a number of reasons.
And what we see here
is embedded bones.
They are long human bones
that are embedded on the wall.
There's one there, another
one here, and there.
My assumption as a
bioarchaeologist,
I believe these are leg bones.
KENNY BROAD: That looks
like it'd be a femur or--
MEMO: Exactly, or tibias.
If you ask me, I would
say, yeah, that might
represent bones of ancestors--
KENNY BROAD: Right.
MEMO: --or people very powerful.
KENNY BROAD: What's
your sense of what
can be behind this wall?
MEMO: Well, I do really
believe that there is something
intentionally positive there.
Given the sacredness of
the site, the importance
of the place within
Chichen Itza,
I believe it could be
a burial back there.
KENNY BROAD: I mean,
it makes logical sense.
MEMO: It makes sense, yes.
Yet, if somebody is buried
here, it was for sure a very
important person, a king.